c'est la poule noire entièrement noir
qui vient d'indonésie cette poule c la
sema ni une race élevé par camille jalu
cette étudiante en 6e année de médecine
participe à sa première période à
montigny le bretonneux avec quelques
volailles et des lapins ça touche est à
la fois mais les deux activités la
principale vu que furent médecine donc
la cécité sorte
et puis ça a touché aussi ma petite
passion aux loisirs à côté les poules
les volailles donc c'était fait pour moi
c'était parfait et je suis ravi alors
avec ma fille on regarde l épaule et ses
magnifiques poule et c'est super beau
lapin j'aime bien les animaux
quand j'envoie j'aime les géants river
le caresser vous adoptez des animaux
mais aussi des fleurs et des produits
gastronomiques
au total près de 50 exposants ont
participé à cette 15e édition à la ferme
du man est un événement organisé par le
lion's club de montigny le bretonneux
pour aider au financement de chiens
guides d'aveuglés ça ne se vend pas mais
ça a un coût parce que il faut l'élever
il est élevé au centre de buc juste à
côté
ensuite il faut le nourrir il faut
l'éduquer
il faut tout durant de sa vie le soigner
lui donner à manger et ensuite il faut
lui préparer sa retraite
le lion's club bini montant a déjà
financé cinq chiens guides
avec environ dix mille euros collectés
lors de la pré real 2018
l'organisation va participer au
financement d'un sixième compagnon